[Music]
Good day, today is Monday, October 19,
Andrés González's health, and these are the
most outstanding news,
another shooting was recorded in the Las Vegas hotel zone
today at dawn just outside
the Planet Hollywood hotel, according
to two police reports.  The men got
into a fight in the pedestrian area near the
hotel and during the altercation one of
them drew a gun and fired, according
to authorities, no one was
injured
the two men involved were
arrested a third suspect who
fled the scene was located a few hours
after leaving  on a monday the new
economic relief program for
small businesses is accepting applications
the assistance consists of giving funds
of up to 20 thousand dollars to those who
qualify to pay their
rent bills public services wages
for employees among others
applications are transmitted quickly
funds will arrive in two weeks
after the application is submitted to
the program  ma titled
pandemic emergency technical support or pets grand is not
a loan without a
government grant funds will primarily go
to small businesses
non-profit organizations
chambers of commerce and arts
and culture programs for more information and a
direct link to  request visits
news now dotcom
and now you can live to throw away the
early voting window for the
presidential election began this past Saturday
thousands of voters took advantage to
exercise their civil rights the figures
indicate that more than 50,000 people
submitted their votes in clark county as
well  to avoid delays remember that you can
submit your vote by mail or go in
person and if you have not yet registered you
can do so and participate in these
elections the window to vote
early will be valid until October 30
now we will see the
temperatures we will have warmth for
today with a maximum of 92 degrees
we will continue in the 90s until Thursday  you see and
we will see a decrease for the
weekend with cloudy skies and
temperatures in the 80 degrees is all the
information today have an
excellent day I inform you andrés
gonzález and he left on the
news now in Spanish
[Music]